on Monday two very different videos went
viral the first featured in
eleven-year-old boy Tyler from Conyers
Georgia
Tyler is Allah 18 months old when his
stepfather Don Gauss entered his life
the video shows Tyler approaching his
stepfather reading a letter when I was 1
and a half years old something happened
to me God sent me a real dad dad I've
been your childhood love since I can
remember but I want to be your son
legally will you please adopt me Don
says yes at which point he embraces the
crying boy in a bear hug it's nearly
impossible not to have the odd speck of
dust in your eye while you watch it
meanwhile another heart-rending video
made the rounds this was video of Chris
Gard and Connie Yates parents Vincent
Charlie guard announcement would no
longer attempt to remove Charlie from
the UK for treatment Charlie suffers
from a rare degenerative disease that
ends in death the Great Ormond Street
Hospital refused to release him to his
parents so they could fly him to the
United States on his own dime to seek
experimental treatment instead deciding
the little Charlie should die with
dignity
Chris stated we knew our son which is
why we continued fighting Charlie has
been left with his illness to
deteriorate devastatingly to the point
of no return juxtaposing these two
videos is very awkward for the political
left it's awkward because while what
likes to claim that it stands with
parents it actually promulgates policies
antithetical to parental control of
their children the less will pay lip
service to motherhood and apple pie but
the mother gives her child too much
apple pie it'll call the state to do
something about it that's what happened
with Charlie guard the question is not
whether you agree with guards parents
are not perhaps the doctors were right
and as parents for grasping at straws in
a desperate attempt to ignore the
agonizing reality of the situation the
question is whether parents have the
right to make such decisions to begin
with we're not talking about abusive
parents who physically harm their kids
we're not talking about a child
endangerment scenario we're talking
about parents choosing a culture of life
with which the prevailing leftist
sentiment disagrees there is no
objective standard suggesting that
so-called Death with Dignity
should overcome the value of
preservation of life that is a
subjective decision at best yet the
hospital the UK government and the EU
decided they knew better than Charlie
guy's parents they don't the judges who
decided to charlie dark state have never
met Charlie guard they never spent hours
crying by his bedside or rubbing the
fuzz on his head had Charlie been
healthy they wouldn't have been aware of
him at all if they know better they'd
know better than Charlie's parents what
ought to happen the devaluation of
parenting on the Left isn't restricted
to life and death decisions it reaches
down to the basics of parenting what
value system should be taught to kids
last month
the British
threaten to shut down an Orthodox Jewish
girls school for the crime of not
teaching children the prevailing LGBT
agenda inspectors said it's a fit the
failures teach children about leftist
views of sexual orientation quote
restricts pupils spiritual moral social
and cultural development and does not
promote equality of opportunity in ways
to take account to different lifestyles
unquote this despite the fact that the
inspectors openly acknowledged that the
school's culture is clearly focused on
teaching pupils to respect everybody
regardless of beliefs and lifestyle in
Ontario Canada legislators recently
passed a regulation that would allow the
government to remove children from the
home if parents refuse to accept the
child self-perception as transgender
their excuse failure to do so might
result in damage to the child instead
the government could take hold of the
child placing them in the system and
then promote text transition once again
this has nothing to do with science and
everything to do with politics the roots
of this sustain for parenting Lyon
Rousseau in the romantics who sought
parents is a burden on childhood
childhood freedom and exploration but
the truth is far less stunning for kids
who lack parental guidance they have
higher rates of depression and suicide
higher rates of drug use higher rates of
promiscuity higher rates of involvement
in crime
we need more Criss guards and more Don
Gauss's not more bureaucrats certain
that they know what's best for a child
they'd never met and don't care about
the left however seems determined to
write parents out of the story of their
own children's upbringing the state
knows best how to care for your child on
everything from nutrition to sex ed to
life itself if that means death for a
baby so be it at least the state's view
of the value of life has been
promulgated I'm Ben Shapiro this is a
venture Pierrot show
[Music]
okay a lot to get see today I did
testify on the hill which means that we
have a slightly abbreviated show today
because I have to run for a plane pretty
soon but before we get to everything
that happened on the hill which is
really fascinating action thoughts on it
and everything that is happening over at
the White House which is also
fascinating and I have some thoughts and
before I even get to the scandal that
nobody is talking about inside the
Democratic Party first I want to say
thank you to our sponsors over at links
so we are thrilled to partner with link
they are the world's first and only
personalized wine club the way that this
works is that you go over to win try
wyndcomm it's t ry winc calm if you
don't know anything about wine I don't
know anything about one what you can do
is you go over there and they have an
algorithm where you type in the kinds of
foods that you like they give you a
brief survey and then they tell you what
kind of wine we pair best as a
particular meal this is fantastic so
when you're going over to somebody's
house and you don't know what bottle of
wine to buy it you don't want to spend
$80 on a nice bottle of wine so instead
you go over to try wink calm it tell you
exactly the one that will pair best and
then they send you the wine in the mail
and it is terrific wine people in the
office have said that it is it is really
good and you can tell from our
production quality too drunk appetizers
that's how good the wine is over a try
wink calm right now they're offering
listeners 20 $20 off their first order
when they go to try blink comm flash
then they even cover the cost of
shipping again it's tri wink winc comm
slash benz get 20 bucks off your first
order now plus complimentary shipping
again that is tri wink comm slash been
try wink comm slash bend they'll
recommend you the best wine then they
will give you the best wine okay so
there's a lot of stuff happening right
now all of it
bizarro world over on the Democratic
side of the aisle everybody's covering
what's happening the White House so
before I even get to what is happening
in the White House I first want to
discuss what is happening with the
Democrats because as I reported
yesterday in Ron Owen was a democratic
IT consultant and he was apparently
stealing laptops from Democratic members
of Congress and then he was selling them
and they found a bunch of smashed
equipment in his house he had access to
some of their passwords he had debbie
Wasserman Schultz's computer and her
password that gave him access to a lot
of DNC material and he was caught trying
to flee the country in wire $300,000 for
himself in Pakistan w Wasserman Schultz
only fired him on the day that he was
captured by the police he was paid he
alone his family members feel like 4
million
of the last several years to do IT for
the Democrats and what's weird the
Debbie wasserman-schultz has been trying
to pressure the police to hand over her
laptop and that's evidence in an ongoing
local case right I mean this is this is
a this is an actual crime and debbie
Wasserman Schultz apparently called up
the Chief of Police in DC and yelled at
him that you wanted her laptop back and
threatened him that she want her laptop
back so Rhonda McDaniel who is the chair
of the RNC she says that it's pretty
clear that debbie Wasserman Schultz has
something to hide here else I see worker
facing charges for bank fraud this
morning accused of double billing the
government for computer equipment but
they caught him as he was trying to flee
the country at Dulles Airport the
authorities arrested in Ron Alana Dulles
where he had a flight booked to Pakistan
through Qatar several relatives of the
37 year old were fired months ago as
well and Iran was kept on staff by
Wasserman Schultz for reasons we are
just we have no idea why she waited so
long to fire him but Ron I'm wondering
if there's a lot more to this I know
that he's facing charges of bank fraud
but does he have ties to the Muslim
Brotherhood is this more about terrorism
than just bank fraud we have to get to
the bottom of this and debbie Wasserman
Schultz has obstructed at every level on
something that affects potentially our
national security so to have this
gentleman try and leave the country
yesterday and now we know there's bank
fraud and we know he destroyed these
hard drives and when you talk when you
read the story about the marine that
found them and the apartment he was
trying to run I mean it is it's a long
story but it's something we have to get
to the bottom of we're not hearing the
Democrats talk about it at all right
well we can talk back there she's
totally right they're not they're not
talking about imagine if Speaker of the
House Paul Ryan somebody had tried to
flee the country after having stolen
Ryan's hard drive and smashed a bunch of
hard drives of other members of Congress
apparently and Paul Ryan had hired him
up til identity flood minutes
immediately fired him and also he
wouldn't let the police do their full
investigation
imagine if that's what had happened it'd
be insane right I mean the left would
never like oh it would be the end of the
world
it'd be the end of the world but the
left is ignoring this as far as they
can't and the question is why the
question is why all of this was
happening you know and and the only
rational answer I can come
with obviously is that not only just
wasserman-schultz have something to hide
but it has something to do with the
information on her laptop
now does that tie to another story that
the left is largely ignoring so the
seven Democrats yesterday attempted to
prevent a witness from fusion GPS from
testifying fusion GPS you'll recall with
the research firm that was commissioned
by interests aligned with Democratic
Party to produce the dossier of Trump
intelligence including all the crap
about the P tape so that was fusion GPS
well the Senate is currently
investigating this Gordon weekly
standard
the Senate is investigating allegations
that elements of the Trump campaign may
have been colluding with Russia but now
an interesting angle has emerged fusion
GPS is now accused of simultaneously
being hired to work for putin's moneyed
interests in the west using gps is
apparently representing the same Putin
connected interests when they were
involved in arranging the controversial
meeting Donald's from jr. Jared Kushner
and Paul Manafort had with Rinat
Akhmetov
a former Russian intelligence offer an
officer and Russian lawyer Natalia best
elements kya our vessel I think to
pronounce furthermore the firm also
being accused of engaging in unethical
and illegal behavior while representing
Russian connected interest so what it
looks like is that the Russians were not
intent on having Trump elected or just
attacking Hillary Clinton the Russians
were also attempting to go after
president Trump then candidate Trump by
essentially working with and hiring
fusion GPS to build this Oppo file on
Trump according to the Weekly Standard
Bill Browder's of Finance here with an
extensive history of dealings in Russia
his testimony before the Senate
Judiciary Committee on Wednesday is
worth reading in full because the
machination czar complicated but briefly
the story is this
after Browder exposed the corrupt
financial practices of putin's cronies
Putin came after Browder personally
deport him in 2005 and 18 months later
seizing all the documents related to his
investment in the country Browder with
the help of a guy named Sergei Magnitsky
who is a who is a Russian dissident
filed criminal complaints about Russian
officials stealing from the country's
tax coppers rather than came to
Washington DC and effusion GPS
eventually ended up arranging a meeting
between Don Trump jr. and aqua aqua chin
and vessel mitts kaya se says fusion GPS
according the Browder was behind that
meeting which means that the Russians
were hiring a Democrat connected
firm to set up the meeting with Donald
Trump jr. that's basically the
allegation so it's getting a little
complicated here but what it looks like
is that it could be a setup
right it looks like not that down Trump
pewter sure to take the meaning that
doesn't let him off dog but like the
Democratic operatives we're working with
the Russians in order to try and trap
Donald from jr. I mean that seems to be
the the explanation that is being given
by this guy Bill Browder who knows a lot
of the players and this is getting into
deep stuff according to Thor Halvorssen
president CEO of the human rights
foundation
he has alleged effusion GPS is operating
in violation of the foreign agent
Registration Act a fusion GPS has
previously been in the news for the
harassment of Republican campaign donors
in the 2012 presidential election as of
yesterday investigative reporter former
investigative reporter Glenn Simpson who
is the founder of fusion GPS he refused
to testify before the Senate and said
that he would invoke his Fifth Amendment
right so again this is a story that is
being under covered when it's being
dramatically under covered because of
course it has to do it's wrong and it
has to do with the Russians involvement
with a democratic oriented firm that was
attempting to gather information on
Donald Trump and it's undercuts the
entire narrative Democrats of course the
media are ignoring this as far as they
possibly can it ought not be ignored
this is important stuff if you are going
to say that all of the if you're going
to make the case that everything ought
to be investigated and that Trump
oughtta be investigated for his Russian
connections you have to make the same
case about using GPS you have to make
the same case about Ukrainian
interference with Hillary Clinton all of
these things are a must so this is it's
not quite as Queen kind of cases the
left wants to make it the Trump colluded
with Russia so when when the election it
looks like Russia was doing what the
intelligence he said it was doing
remember there's a disagreement among
the intelligence he she felt that Russia
was involved in the election cycle even
among the intelligence he's there was a
basic disagreement on one question and
the question was did Russia want Trump
to win and most the intelligence
agencies were saying no it wasn't about
Russia wanting Trump to win it was just
about them screwing with the election
which means they were screwing with the
election from both sides then we're
going fusion GPS allegedly on the left
and then they were working with Donald
Trump jr. on the right they were just
trying to get their hands muddy and
banking on everybody being dishonest in
order to do that turns out that may have
been a very good bet well before we get
to before we get to the latest with
Anthony Skinner Moochie and the end
battle that's now going on
Queen Anthony scare emoji and Reince
Priebus I first want to say thank you to
our sponsors over at frame bridge comm
it is the best way the easiest way to
frame your favorite art and photos
without ever having to leave your house
with their simple online ordering
process you can order a fully customized
piece in minutes to go to frame bridge
comm you upload your photo from your
computer or directly from instagram or
if you have physical item then they will
send you a packaging you can send it
back to them then you can preview your
photo online in any frame style then
we'll even though custom frame your item
in days and instead of hundreds their
prices start at 39 bucks all shipping is
free and all the frames are just
beautiful and they'll even help you work
with a talented designer who will help
you pick what your frame should look
like my listeners right now get 15% off
their first order when they go to frame
bridge comm its frame bridge comm using
promo code Shapiro and by the way if
they're not happy with it they offer
100% guarantee it's a happiness
guaranteed they will make it right again
its frame abridge calm and use that
promo code Shapiro you'll save that 15%
off your first order it's much more
inexpensive it's much less expensive
than going down to the local photo
framing shop so it's better is what's
expensive you're enough to leave your
house and you get 15% discount when you
go to frame bridge calm and use that
promo code Shapiro make sure that you do
it because they are great sponsors and
let them know that we sent you as well
okay so the latest on scare emoji is
that there's there's a lot of how about
breaking out inside the Trump White
House now it seems like half because a
man at the top doesn't seem like he is
laying down the law for all the talk
about trumping great CEO the truth is
for a very long time
Trump has functioned in a world where he
sort of acts like the Joker in that
scene with the two leftover thugs from
the other guys gang ready sort of breaks
a pool cue throws it down and says oh he
wouldn't use any did you hopper it this
is Trump's routine right now the two
people who stopped a piece of Paquito
are Reince Priebus and Anthony Skinner
movie now he obviously loves skin emoji
because scaramouche went on TV and was
highly complementary to him for several
months and ripped down CNN and got
contender attractive story which is like
the Holy Grail in Trump world so he
loved Anthony Skinner Meucci he is less
enamored of Reince Priebus he has been I
mean has been every two weeks
talk about Reince Priebus being fired
and that is alive once again people are
talking about that again and scaramouche
E this time it actually looks like
to make that happen so scary Moochie
yesterday tweeted out that he thought
basically the Reince Priebus was the
leaker and so essentially he tweeted out
yesterday that that there was a felony
that had taken place and that Reince
Priebus this was the implication the
Ryan's previous had leaked his public
disclosures no there's a couple problems
with this number one you can't leak
public disclosures in public so all his
financial disclosures those became
public like several days ago and it
wasn't a leak but he accused somebody of
a felony and then he directed the tweet
outlines right well he directed it
directly at Reince Priebus the reason
he's angry is because it appears from
Politico like scary movies profits from
the sale of his hedge fund group are
apparently he's still receiving those
profits and he has not divested himself
from his old firm and then scare Moochie
went on CNN he said that putting rights
rights his name at the end of tweet
didn't mean that he wanted Ryan's
investigate he said who's going to send
the FBI and the DOJ information about
the leaks and then he tagged grinds at
the end and people are like whoa so
you're reporting Ryan's previous to the
DOJ and the FBI and apparently according
to multiple media reports Ryan Lizza was
one of them at the Washington Post
apparently that's exactly what happened
scare Moochie suspected that Reince
Priebus was leaking on him and so he
went outside to the DOJ and the FBI so
scary Moochie went on national TV Ryan
Lizza was on CNN and Skinner Moochie
calls in and it gets really really weird
it's really really weird so he says that
he and prove its are like brothers who
fight a lot some brothers are like Cain
and Abel others fight but get along the
implication of course is that they were
the latter and maybe more like the
former he says now if you want to talk
about the chief of staff we've had we
have had oz we've had differences when I
said we were brothers from the podium
that's because we're up on one another
some brothers like amedeo Cain and Abel
other brothers brothers can fight each
other and get along I don't know if this
is reparable or not that will be up to
the president and then he and then he
said that he was going to take down
leakers he said the leakers are traitors
in a century ago
if you leaked it would have gotten you
hung which is not really true and then
he he says that he and Trump have a very
very good idea of who the senior leakers
are in the White House she said it's
absolutely completely totally
reprehensible and as you know from the
Italian expression the fish things from
the head down but I can tell you two
fish that don't stink and that's
in the president to Skinner Mookie doing
exactly what Trump would want them to do
which is kiss Trump's ass shamelessly in
public and also hit people Trump liked
the sport of this and so if you like
that Skinner move she is really militant
so it appears that wine is in serious
trouble may in fact be on his way out
Rhine says that he's sticking around of
course everybody says they're sticking
around and now there's a report that
descendant is beginning to buck so this
was always the question could there be a
point where people say to where people
say to Trump in the Senate and in
Congress we're not going any further
than this and it appears that the
sessions thing and maybe the right thing
these are these are a little bit of a
breaking point from the session thing
because if he gets rid of sessions the
Senate has to approve a new Attorney
General and senators are all friends
obsessions remember sessions was part of
their caucus until five minutes ago and
so Lindsey Graham came out and he said
listen if we if you fire Attorney
General Sessions and Grassley said the
two chuck Grassley from Iowa exit you're
not getting a hearing there will be no
new hearings I'm an attorney general
you'll just have to serve with broad
Rosenstein at the acting Attorney
General and there's nothing you can do
about it because we're not going to
allow you to oust session so there's
beginning to be a bit of a spine from
Congress with regard to Trump and other
edge stuff sessions is the right places
to do all of this but there is a lot of
chaos right now there is a bet that
they're betting pools which one is going
to be first to go is going to be Rimes
is going to be session is going to be a
Tom Price it's going to be Tillerson who
is now on vaycay is it going to be
Madison Madison talked about leaving and
Trump isn't talking about asking him but
the Pentagon released a statement today
saying they weren't changing their
transgender policy pending more
information from the president which
means they really haven't been
coordinating on any of that you know all
of this is just a big wake-up call to
the Trump administration if Trump is
capable of being awoken this is just the
entire Republican base well not the
entire Republican base the entire base
in Congress the people who are capable
of checking Trump saying listen to get
your crap together please get your crap
together and it gets worse than that
okay so in a second I'm going to talk
about what's happening with regard to
Alaska because it's getting pretty rough
where Trump is actually putting pressure
on the last couple of different source
the interior secretary Ryan's inky got
the middle of it we'll explain what's
happening there and we'll get to
transgender policy and why everybody is
wrong about everything we'll get to all
of those things but for that
has to go over to daily wired.com and
subscribe over at daily wire.com for
just $9.99 a month you too can be a
member of the daily wire that means that
you get this show live it means that you
get to be part of our video mailbag
which we do tomorrow it is a video show
for people who just listen and it's
worthwhile seeing because we play all
the clips you can see my amazing facial
expressions and if you spend $99 then
you can see the mug that I will be
holding up when I get back to Los
Angeles this of course is the most
fantastic tumbler of all time the annual
subscription comes they left this tears
hot or cold mug and it is just
magnificent steven crowder has said that
it is filled with goo gold I will not
say whether or not that is true you'll
have to buy it to find out but $99 gets
you the annual subscription and that
fabulous fabulous tumbler that you'll
treasure all your life and pass on to
your grandchildren or just wanna listen
later go over to iTunes or SoundCloud
and check us out make sure you leave us
a review we always appreciate it we are
the largest conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]
okay so meanwhile while all this is
going on inside the White House and
Anthony Skinner Moochie continues to
defend he says that people don't
understand Trump right I mean it's the
Trump lives in the White House in the
elite stones and so sit down and shut up
you're scaramouche you're doing that
routine last night you'll see that the
Bates and the majority of the American
people and certainly all of the American
people that voted form either don't care
about the tweaks they find them funny
they find them refreshing they don't
generally know if it's right they don't
overreact and Michael analyzing the way
you guys actually not with the survey
show shows most people don't think that
they're appropriate and aren't big fans
of him but he is playing well okay but
you know what they're still voting for
me still the president they voted for
let's see that's a trial is that worth
living as an answer every time I checked
he's living in the residence up here and
really torn okay so this constant
refrain that Trump can do whatever he
wants because you want that doesn't mean
that he's governing well and this is a
problem Skinner movie though this is
really more about scaramouche
auditioning for Trump a lot of the
campaign has been a lot of the
administration has now been about
showing from the oil and showing in the
air a tough guy and all the scaramouche
he uses this kind of language and I
think from loved it
Skinner Moochie says I don't stab people
in the back I stab people in the front
what I don't like about Washington is
people do not let you know how they feel
they're very nice to your face and then
they take a shiv or a machete and they
stab it in your back I don't like it
you know Anthony I like Romo I'm a Wall
Street guy and I'm more of a front
stabbing person and I'd rather tell
people directly how I feel about this
okay so this is a kind of talk that
Trump likes the question is is it going
to be effective so another example of
something being ineffective so Trump is
trying to put pressure on Lisa Murkowski
to vote for the Senate bill that's fine
I mean he should put pressure on Lisa
Murkowski to vote for some form of
repeal I mean they just keep shrinking
down what exactly it is they're going to
vote for and I was on the hill this
morning that several Congress people
they're deeply frustrated with the
Republicans in the Senate who won't vote
for any form of repeal at all so Trump
is exactly right to go after Murkowski
but apparently last night Trump and
apparently previs and Skinner Moochie
they they all sort of made threats
toward the toward the Alaskan senator
they said that we're going to start
reregulate or at least not deregulating
the Alaskan energy industry unless you
give us your vote and then Murkowski
immediately responded by refusing to see
any of the nominees for the
undersecretary positions over the
Interior Department where Ryan's Enki is
working so it's just battle royale
between Trump and everybody right now
it's a war of all against all the reason
that this matters the reason that this
is bad is because what we're watching
right now it is not just important to do
the right thing in politics and in terms
of doing some of the right things you
have to do the right thing in the right
way the reason the right way matters is
because what happens after you do the
same right so Obama thought he did the
right thing with Obamacare but the way
he did it was the wrong way and that's
what led to 70 percent disapproval
ratings on Obama care even though now
people you know by and large are largely
positive about Obama care the same thing
is happening with regard to the internet
salutes with the poll show the same
thing is happening with regard to
single-payer health care and like if
Trump goes too far on health care and he
does it in a way that people don't
appreciate they're going to hate no
matter what he proposes how it got done
and there's going to be blowback and
that actually ends up helping Democrats
because remember if you do this wrong
and people react badly they're going to
vote for Democrats in 2018 and 2020 and
then the Democrats will have their shot
at reimplemented the Democrats are
becoming very open about their agenda
here so if you do it wrong and you hand
at the time to the other guy then
they're not going to be shy about
cramming that baton down your throat
here is Senator Dick Durbin from
Illinois says listen whatever happens
here we're going to move closer to
single-payer on the other side and
Senator Durbin this is Eddie Glaude
let's pin out a little bit there you the
Democratic Party just released its
better deal to kind of offer a vision of
their policy initiatives over over the
next few years
there's clam Derek's clamoring among the
base for single single-payer how in the
course of this debate will you respond
to those of us on the left who really
think that thing or pet single-payer
might be the answer to the health care
issue this is a last gasp but we're
going through now is the last gasp for
private health insurance in America as
far as I'm concerned if we can't make
this work with the private health
insurance industry we start moving
closer to a Medicare model from my point
of view Medicare has a lot of positive
of things to offer the American people
how many folks say darn it now I qualify
for Medicare most of them say hooray I
don't have to worry about pre-existing
conditions I've paid into it I can get
the best hospitals and doctors and I
have peace of mind that's what people
are looking for in health insurance and
if it is a point the Democrats are the
Democrats are already moving for less
this is the point Democrats are already
moving to less if you do something that
makes a good policy unpopular that is
almost worse than doing nothing at all
and this is my problem with had from
dragged out the transgender policy
change that he did yesterday
the fact that Trump did it via tweet
poisoned the well a little bit because
it made it difficult to defend imagine
that instead of doing that Trump had
gone to General Madison said you had
understand it was six months study I
want you to accelerate the study and
then I want you to come out with results
and I want you to tell the world why do
you think the transgender people serving
in the military is bad for the military
and then Maddox came forward and said
listen as someone you served my entire
life in the military as somebody who
cares deeply about unit cohesion it's
important that we not do this very
difficult for the left to take the
opposing viewpoint instead from tweets
out something and everybody runs for the
hills and it looks most of all
disrespectful to people who are
transgender and currently serving in the
military now listen I am NOT I mean if
you listen to the show at all or watch
the show at all you know that I believe
the transgenderism is a gender dysphoria
is mental illness and they are some ring
from a severe mental disorder and as a
general rule bringing in groups of
people who have severe mental disorders
in the military is not a strong move is
it point to David French former military
guy and that he makes over a national
review that when you look at military
policy it's sort of like when you look
at insurance policy we in regular life
when we deal with each other on a
one-to-one basis we expect to be treated
as individuals not as members of groups
but when you are doing actuarial
selections right when you are doing an
insurance table they don't have to get
to know every aspect of you they look at
your age they look at your prior health
and they say okay based on the
information we have there's a good
likelihood you'll be dead in 30 years so
here's here's we're going to charge you
that's how they do this and that's not
about devaluing you as a human being
it's using probability theory to gauge
what's going to happen the same thing
happens when you decide which groups to
recruit for the military and who should
be allowed in if you had a group among
which there was a significant I'm
talking forty percent rate of
schizophrenia you can bet that group
would have a hard time being recruited
into the military
again it could manifest at any time and
you don't want to be in a position where
this entire group of people are getting
skits are seeing the symptoms of
schizophrenia on the battlefield when
they're under pressure the same thing is
true for gender dysphoria so all of the
virtue signaling from left is really
ridiculous but it was made possible in
part because Trump did the right thing
the wrong way it's important for term to
start doing the right thing the right
way you can see the reporters virtual
signaling yesterday at the White House
every reporter felt the necessity to get
up and speak openly and passionately
about transgender soldiers in the
military apparently they're about 4,000
active duty transgender soldiers in the
military that seems high to me I'm not
sure how many of those people are open
about their transgenderism but in any
case here the reporter is just virtru
signalling one after another is the
president considering looking at any
kind of policy about transgender people
serving the White House identities tried
to make a decision on transgender people
service military no once again this is a
decision based on what was best for the
military and a military cohesion and on
the counsel of his national security
team thank you so the impression they
were a little bit flat little bit flat
footed by the president's tweet so I
understand that this was and has been to
last couple weeks of conversation here
specifically about TRICARE coverage for
transgender procedures and it suddenly
evolved after the president to then go
on Twitter to announce this man and as
you already told us the White House and
the Pentagon are gonna have to lawfully
implement that typically when you have
announcement of this magnitude all that
work has been done at the procedural
level between the bureaucracy of the
Pentagon in the White House
why wasn't any of that work done and why
was the Pentagon caught so surprised
this morning by the president's tweet
some yeah as I said before that the
president's national security team was
part of this consultation you mentioned
yourself that there have been ongoing
conversations when this one smaller
president makes it back right when the
president made the decision yesterday
the Secretary of Defense was immediately
informed as were the rest of the
national security team we couldn't stop
there I mean bottom line is that again
if Trump had gone to Madison like mattis
be the tip of the spear or if we laid
out a long essay or if he had laid out
if you had given cerrado be Sanders
talking points all of this could have
been avoided instead all you're seeing
all over the TV is Caitlyn Jenner angry
at Trump now imagine if you want to
paint room general versus trunk or
Caitlyn Jenner versus Mad Dog Madison
when's that public relations battle but
here's Caitlyn Jenner doing his routine
and
and Trump does not look the better for
we're on this Caitlyn Jenner tweeted
there are 15,000 patriotic transgender
Americans in US military fighting for
all of us what happened to your promise
to fight for them now remember again it
would be very difficult for Caitlyn
Jenner to make that case if it were
general mattis who had actually laid out
this policy she's doing the right thing
the wrong way is sometimes even worse
than doing nothing and that's not again
a rip on policy choices that Trump made
with regarded transgender soldiers I'm
fully in agreement because I think that
most military minds who put aside to
political correctness understand that
putting a group of people in harm's way
who are 40 percent lifetime suicide rate
90 percent of military veterans who are
transgender have been diagnosed with a
mental illness after leading the service
you know none of this bodes well for
building the best fighting force in the
world and again you have small units of
soldiers on the front line day after day
after day that's not exactly a pressure
free environment if they have a 44
transgender people have 40 percent
lifetime suicide rate in the United
States which is a pretty welcoming
environment try it when you're a soldier
in Afghanistan I mean that's just not
going to go well so again I think Trump
can be right but he has to get over
doing it the wrong way and it's actually
a deeply important thing so before I get
some things I like and some things I
hate I first want to say thank you to
our sponsors over at blankets so you
have a lot of stuff going on today I
justify it on the hill and I'm doing the
show and I did a bunch of interviews I
still had time to read a book I don't
have time to read a book because I was
using my blinka staff while I walked the
blinkin staff allows you to essentially
sample you get a summary of
or 2,000 was the best-selling
non-fiction books transformed into this
powerful packets you can listen to in 50
minutes it's not a full summary of the
book because it doesn't go through every
point of the book but it picks the most
important points from any of these books
and then gives it to you so in 15
minutes you get the main point of a book
which is great because the fact is even
if you were to read a 500 page book
you're probably not going to obtain more
than three or four minutes worth of
material on it anyway so having having
it boiled down into 15-minute forms that
you can get the main gist of it we do it
every day in our lives we should be
doing it with books - that's a blink it
is for we're talking great books like
why nation sale again
600 page book boiled down into 15
minutes you can get into 2 to 3 books a
day writing it through two or three
books a day just by going to blankest
right now go to blink it's calm bli n ki
st blink is calm / been to start your
free trial or get three months off your
yearly plan again it's blankets calm /
bend and go over and check it out and
and you will not be disappointed it is
fantastic you get that free trial three
months off your yearly plan when you
join today everybody that I know who's
used it loves it I was talking to Dana
Perino the other day and she said she's
been using blankets because because you
heard it on the show it's just great so
make sure that you check out blankets
actually congressman said his wife uses
blankets now because because of
listening to the show so make sure that
you go there use the promo code that
lets them know that we sent you plus it
means that you're going to get that
discount so pretty pretty awesome okay
so time for some things I like and some
things that I hate so things that I like
so I did testify on the hill today I'll
have clips of it tomorrow we'll play
them on the show it was a lot of fun
something I've never done before the
panel was an eighteen Strawson from the
ADL is on my right and then Adam Carolla
was on my left and there were two
administrators a fellow whose name I
can't recall from Evergreen State
College another very end a fellow named
uh last name Lawrence who was the Dean
at Brandeis University and networks for
the anti-defamation league and I had
some basic thoughts first of all it's
great the representative Jim Jordan from
the fourth District of Ohio he put the
thing together
and it was just fabulous because it's
taking on a much needed issue that has
been ignored for too long which is a
threat to free speech that's happening
on campus so good for representative
Jordan good for the other members the
committee including ranking Democrats
for getting together on this thing
putting it together it's it was
interesting because I think that some of
the main issues were sort of skirted
over with regard to free speech so the
main issue which is that people should
be allowed to say what they want on
campus speakers should be allowed to
speak everyone basically agreed with
that but there are several people on the
left side of the aisle that kept saying
we'll just leave it to administrators
just leave it to administrators and I
could say there has to be some sort of
ramification for administrators if they
do not do their job if they use the
restrictions they have available to them
to politically buy it the discussion by
banning certain speakers and I didn't
really have a chance to say but I wanted
to that if you have a administration
where if I come to speak they released a
letter to the entire student body saying
this guy doesn't represent us but then
you have kind of PC codes come to speak
and there's no letter that goes out
that's a chilling effect on the
expression of a different point of view
there should be a blanket rule on public
university campuses that if you're going
to have any speaker that the university
will say this person does not represent
us under story end of story
but there's this attempt to to promote
sensitivity that is in conflict with the
the notion of free speech because free
speech is not about sensitivity
it's about suck it up buttercup and
there and the left wants to sort of have
it both ways so the well it's was Beth
in was to watch how the Democratic
attempted to turn the hearing from what
about administrative malfeasance on
campus into a hearing about hate crimes
on campus and about people who are who
are they kept bringing up this case of
this this young black woman who is the
student body president over at American
University Taylor Dunford and I think
I'm pronouncing the last name correctly
and and she was finishes left the
student president and then apparently
around campus people were stringing up
nooses with bananas in them and they had
they'd put on the bananas a reference
sorority that she attended I don't I'd
never seen the story before so I really
didn't know much about it so I'll take
it if they value obviously that's
horrible and the administration looked
into it and the administration is going
to do something about it and that's the
point and I did say this too - I think
it's represent of Eleanor Norton Holmes
Holmes Norton I believe I said to her
there is a massive difference between
individuals on campus doing terrible
things which we all agree you know if
you give it a crime which is in an
actress saying something offensive but
you're
actively what you're doing can be
interpreted or should be interpreted by
a reasonable person as as an actual
threat of violence then that's crime but
if the idea here is that that's the same
thing as an administration that's
attempting to crack down on free speech
it is not so there's that thing to watch
as Democrats try to redirect this into
the alt-right is the real threat on
campus okay it's not okay it's not the
fact is that the threats of violence are
in the main not coming from the right on
campus because the right doesn't really
exist on campus or at least if it does
it exists in very small measure there's
a very small group of all right people
who may be terrible on campus but that
is certainly not a vast bevy of problems
on campus and I'm speaking as someone
who's Jewish
and there have been a lot of hate crimes
you know so-called hate crimes against
Jews and on campus a lot of those by the
way are coming from what so it was fun
to watch as the Democrats tried to twist
away from just saying you should be
allowed to say what you want on campus
enough of the stupid diversity training
enough of the administrative malfeasance
let's focus on letting everybody speak
freely they were very upset actually
about this Wisconsin bill that is
passing is passed through the assembly
over there in Wisconsin largely on the
heels of my lecture University of
Wisconsin Madison where a bunch of
people invaded the lecture stood in
front of the stage and then insisted on
not allowing me to speak and the
administration allowed that to go
forward the Democrats kept tripping on
this and the problem is the bill itself
doesn't say that the bill is is meant to
prevent people from preventing other
people's speech instead the way they
interpret is was they're trying to shut
down protests no one's trying to shut
down protests now maybe have promised
the wording of the bill but the idea
that you that protest allowable protest
involves shutting down other people's
free speech is just asinine I have some
ideas about the workings of the
committee itself and what Republicans
should do better because I think some
Republicans were great and some
Republicans were not as strong Democrats
universally were on message with regard
to what they're attempting to push and
also how they were pursuing their
question they're also some great moments
but we'll go through that much more in
detail tomorrow and we can actually cut
the audio for you because we literally
just finished and then came over here to
arenít foundation our friends at
Heritage allowed us to broadcast from
there today so that's great okay time
for a quick thing that I hate and then
we'll do the big idea and leave so
things I hate
for people who say that all Muslims in
the United States are moderate that
there's no such thing as well happy
funded math that's scary and that we
should never worry about radical Islamic
extremism inside the United States
this tape is now murdered a california
imam is quite prominent who has who's
appearing to call for the annihilation
of you'd and apparently they're not two
of them who were doing this here is tape
of this california imam talking about
the jews Lohani who I knew fundamental
mister hot today Rob Muhammad immunity
I'll have judgments a little Muslim
Jerry or she'll hide behind
authoritarian or so job yeah most
intelligent reasonable Muslim a certain
haha yeah Abdullah Linea podium sweetly
want a or do not need more now no Laurel
curator Apple challenge any that the
time will come the loss our would not
take place to the Muslims fight the Jews
Romanian solution for invested in up so
say your ability Muslim mrs. Cornell
Arsenal in Macedon of swimming a dinner
filio a la la la Li la campaña what I
wanted an upside asteroid emoji Allahu
Liman Marinetti human s where the arena
see him are je veux pas de logic logic
embedded Roxie mother is what a cancer
again cell for Nia Lauren how do you
must do the love soil but I mean okay
madam he says Allah count them one by
one annihilate them down to the very
last ones do not spare any of them this
is a lot like a lot of the sermons that
are out of the Middle East it was posted
to the Islamic Center of Davis's YouTube
channel on Friday the sermon last about
two and a half minutes and that remember
the al-aqsa mosque is only open because
the the Jews allow it to be open and it
was Palestinians who I got the story
wrong the other day slightly miss Hollis
Indians who decided that would be
worthwhile to step step to Druze Israeli
police officers and then we're shot for
their trouble and one of them one of the
attackers is still alive apparently
sadly because evil people should stab
people should die but this is you know
the idea that Islamic extremism is a
tiny tiny percentage of the population
worldwide is not true in the United
States thank God it's so fringe element
but across the world it is certainly not
French certainly not in the Palestinian
Authority and
when you're seeing this kind of stuff
set in the United States it should be
slightly disturbing okay I want to say
something in the big idea so on
Thursdays we have the big idea the big
idea is where we take a concept you may
have heard about but you don't know that
much about in politics let me break it
down for you so that you can use it
yourself so one of the things that you
hear a lot whenever there's a
constitutional case that comes up is you
will hear that justices will say things
like this law had to be we had to apply
strict scrutiny to this law or
intermediate scrutiny to this law or
rational basis review these are legal
tests to determine what rationale the
government has to come up with in order
to regulate something so for example
strict scrutiny that's invoked when
there's a fundamental right at stake so
there's a First Amendment violation but
through the law there the law violates
the First Amendment the question is is
that allowed or not because the First
Amendment is not unlimited right I can't
like walk into your house and just start
shouting there's a compelling state
interest in preventing me from walking
into your house and shouting at you
strict scrutiny is invoked here strict
scrutiny is invoked on a fundamental
right it's take the government can only
regulate these fundamental rights when
there is a quote/unquote compelling
state interest and the regulation is
narrowly tailored as possible and one of
the big questions in the upcoming
masterpiece cake shop case is going to
be whether the discrimination law is
tailored closely enough to prevent the
violation of the fundamental right to
practice your religion intermediate
scrutiny is the next level this is any
this is this is usually related to
discrimination on the basis of gender or
sex so if there's a law that says that
you have to have separate bathrooms for
men and women for example that would
fall under intermediate scrutiny you
have to show the government is allowed
to show that it can discriminate on the
basis of sex for an important government
objective and that the Act is
substantially related to achieving that
objective and finally there's rational
basis review where the person
challenging the law has to show that the
government has no real interest in law
or policy there's no link between the
interest in the challenged law now here
is the problem here these kinds of terms
thrown around especially on the left
they like to throw these terms around
what they mean something they don't mean
anything the first rule of
constitutional law is that it has
nothing to do with the Constitution
these are made up terms they are made up
by by judges and they are twisted to fit
the facts we will see cases that ought
to fall under intermediate scrutiny all
under strict scrutiny you'll see cases
that are
intermediate scrutiny cases that are
treated as though there's strict
scrutiny cases these malleable terms of
art don't mean anything and it's
dangerous and excuse me when you see
justices attempting to apply vague
standards to the law instead of just the
words of the Constitution themselves
this is why I think the Clarence Thomas
is very load to use these sorts of terms
he's exactly right as soon as you start
talking about what sort of scrutiny is
appropriate you're now living in Judge
land you're not looking in Constitution
land anymore so anytime you hear someone
say well that deserves strict scrutiny
just think to yourself I have no idea
what that means and why don't you
actually tell me what the Constitution
has to say about this particular issue
don't be fooled by the legal jargon it's
this is pretty much meaningless legal
jargon that allows people to stretch to
their their perceived wanted conclusion
at any point okay we'll be back tomorrow
now look back in our beautiful la
Studios and I will be doing the mailbag
as well so make sure that you check that
out Plus will be playing excerpts from
my testimony on Capitol Hill which is a
lot of fun but we'll do all of that i'm
ben shapiro this is the bench bureau
show
[Music]